Existence is strange and there’s no way
we can ever manage to understand all the many
mysteries of life, the universe and everything.
When we come across something we don’t understand,
most of us turn to teachers, parents, smart
friends and probably Wikipedia, in an attempt
to sort out what’s what.
Some people though, like to close their eyes,
stick out their finger and believe whatever
crazy solution it lands on.
And this isn’t just reserved for the darkest
corners of the internet, many well-known public
figures and celebrities have dived head first
into the pool of pseudoscience, conspiracies,
and good old fashioned nonsense.
Today we look at 5 famous people with outrageous
theories and beliefs.
Gravity seems to be a problem in a number
of wild theories but one of the best surely
has to come from internet personality David
Avacado Wolfe.
He’s the least famous person on this list,
but he deserves first billing because of the
sheer ludicrousy of his beliefs.
You probably all have a friend who shares
his steady stream of vague and generally harmless
motivational memes.
He has almost 6 million followers on Facebook
and built a career as a raw food enthusiast,
promoting a variety of super foods and supplements.
Oh and he beliefs gravity doesn’t exist
as we know it, it is actually a toxin that
we should get rid of.
There are many videos of him, both interviews
and recordings of public lectures, where he
puts forward a range of theories about various
foods and the body.
But his gravitationally questionable theory
is that he believes salt is basically the
gatekeeper of water and, to quote him, “the
reasons why the oceans are salty is that’s
what’s needed to hold the water onto the
earth, if that didn’t happen the water would
levitate right off the earth and that would
be the end of it.”
He doesn’t say what happens to unsalted
freshwater rivers and lakes but let’s assume
they’re tied down with magic rope or maybe
the fish just grip onto it really, really
tightly.
He loves salt for its ability to keep water
retained in your muscles.
He even recommends just having it around your
home to prevent allergies, insomnia and migraines.
Have you even seen a peanut with a migraine?
No?
Exactly.
But the Wolfe’s expertise do not end there.
Here is a brief outline of some his other
wonderful theories;
“Chocolate lines up planetarily with the
sun, chocolate is an octave of sun energy.”
And that, children, is why you should always
eat up all your KitKats!
But seriously, “chocolate lines up with
the sun”, what does that even mean.
Here’s another omniscient quote of his…
Mushroom spores can “levitate off the planet
because they are surrounded by a shell of
Ormus, which is actually trying to get to
the centre of the sun”
I don’t think mushroom takers intend to
get quite THAT high.
In case you’re curious, ORMUS is an idea
created by David Hudson in 1975; they are
precious metals without molecular bonds; so
all the atoms exist separately.
And yes, you’re right, that is complete
nonsense.
And one more of David Wolfe’s theories is
that:
“Deer antler is not a product.
It's a cosmic substance.”
I’m not sure the deer will feel that way,
as you chop the space horns off their heads.
He believes the horns make you younger.
Did I forget to mention he’s also a flat
earther too, along with a whole load of other
nonsense theories, but we’ll stop there,
I need to go and eat some salt before I float
away again.
Another David now, this time ex-BBC sports
presenter David Icke.
David Icke started out as a goalkeeper.
Unfortunately, arthritis forced him to retire
at just 21 but he went on to carve out a successful
career as a sports presenter, eventually co-hosting
the BBC show Grandstand, the most watched
sports show in the UK.
Due to his arthritis, he began looking into
fringe medicine and new age philosophy, which
led him to become involved with the Green
Party and also to an important meeting with
a psychic, who told him he had been sent to
heal the world.
She didn’t say exactly what was wrong with
the world, some sort of stomach bug I presume.
But nevertheless David Icke was the man to
heal it, apparently.
He began developing an ever more elaborate
theory about why the world had got into such
a state of war, sickness and poverty, realising
that there must be a shadowy cabal behind
all the mischief.
He believes that civilisation was set up by
a group of alien reptiles called the Babylonian
Brotherhood.
Their bloodline continues to this day and
they control everything from the UN to the
media, led by the famous Illuminati, a mysterious
group of world leaders feared by tin foil
hat wearers and internet keyboard warriors
across the world, yes I’m looking at you.
The reptiles came from a constellation called
Draco and were drawn to earth, not for the
margaritas and well organised bus routes,
but for the “monatomic gold”, which is
just another name for the ORMUS that we mentioned
earlier, that impossible form of metal where
none of the atoms are bonded together.
Yes, you’re hearing me correctly, David
Icke believes the world is run by lizards,
with notable figures such as The Queen and
most prime ministers and presidents being
part of this omniscient lizard species.
The reptiles are shape shifting and can take
human from, so you’d better keep your wits
about you.
If you catch anyone looking hungrily at a
dead insect, then it’s probably best to
bow down to them in case they are one of your
overseeing lizard lords.
Oh one more thing, he also believes he is
the son of god.
I’ll just leave that out there.
Do you believe in life after love?
Yes I do, Cher, but I’m not sure I believe
in life after relying solely on homeopathic
treatments.
Cher is not alone in her support of homeopathy,
a whole host of stars from Pamela Anderson
to Tina Turner, Monica Bellucci and many others
have all come out in favour of it.
Now, alternative medicine is a complicated
field, containing many treatments that may
do real good but have yet to be proven scientifically;
things like acupuncture, traditional Chinese
medicine and chiropractic for example.
There is a lot of anecdotal evidence about
their effectiveness but this has not been
backed up by clinical testing, yet.
The same cannot be said however about homeopathy.
Trial after trial has proven, without a doubt,
that the practise has no benefits, beyond
the placebo effect.
In one of the most recent tests, Professor
Paul Glasziou, from Bond university in Australia,
oversaw 176 individual studies and found absolutely
no difference between homeopathy and the placebo
effect for 68 different illnesses.
Hopefully, they can now begin looking into
other more important theories such as; “If
eating carrots helps night vision, if I eat
rabbits will I see in infa-red?”
So, what is homeopathy?
Invented by Samuel Hahnemann in 1796, it follows
three laws; the law of similars, the law of
infinitesimals and the law of succussion.
If the last one sounds like a made up word,
well that’s because it is.
The law of similars means finding a cure that
is similar to the symptoms, such as caffeine
for insomnia or onions to treat the streaming
eyes from hay fever.
Then, the law of infinitesimals means the
more you dilute the substance in water, the
more it increases its potency which is just
as ludicrous and contradictory as it sounds.
The law of succussion just tells you to shake
or tap the container during each mix, so that
the water maintains a “memory” of the
substance.
A lot of medicines are sold as 30C or 100C,
where the C stands for centesimal.
1C is one drop of the substance added to 99
drops of water.
2C is one drop taken from that the previous
solution (which remember is 1% substance,
99% water) and added to another 99 drops of
water.
So 30C is this same process repeated 30 times
over, making it one part per million million
million million million million million million
million million (1 in 1060).
Numbers this big are kind of meaningless so
let me give you an analogy; to dilute one
full drop of a substance in a 30C solution,
you would need enough water to cover every
single planet in 500 million universes.
So I’ll get a bucket, you better start that
rain dance.
Basically, when you buy homeopathic treatments,
you are literally paying for very expensive
water.
When asked, most homeopathy consumers thought
they were actually taking pills containing
some kind of herbal extracts, but in reality
the original substance which was diluted in
it was lost long ago during the repeated dilution
process.
What you’re left with, is water infused
sugar pills.
But, having said all this, the placebo effect
is real, it even works on animals, and something
with a long standing history like homeopathy,
even if it is based on a scientific falsehood
and we have repeatedly proved that it doesn’t
work, is actually still quite likely to work
and be effective on individuals who “believe”
it to be true, because their placebo effect
after the treatment will be more powerful.
Now, if homeopathy requires you to reject
some of your understandings of science, Grammy
nominated rapper B.o.B would like you to tear
up all your text books and make a new paper
mache model of the world.
In his single Flatline he laid out his belief
that we live on a flat earth.
He claims we have all been “Indoctrinated
in a cult called science” and calls out
famous astrophysicist Neil De Grasse Tyson,
claiming he has been paid off.
The scientist, along with his nephew, even
created a retaliation rap.
How did B.o.B end up with his bizarre conclusion
that the world is a spinning plate?
Mankind has actually known the world is round
for a very long time since it explains the
way ships disappear over the horizon and why
during a lunar eclipse it is possible to see
the shadow that Earth makes on the moon and
you can quite clearly see that it’s a sphere.
Flat Earthers believe the world is a disc
with the Arctic Circle in the middle and the
Antarctic acting as a wall of ice surrounding
the big plate.
You can’t walk over the edge because the
wall is guarded by NASA, possibly all disguised
as penguins.
Now I’m sure you have some questions like;
what about the sun?
What about planes and satellites?
And “If earth is a plate, does it mean we’re
someone’s lunch?”
According to flat earthers the sun and moon
are apparently spheres measuring 51 kilometres
across and they move in circles above the
earth, just under 5000 kilometres away, shining
down like spotlights.
The sun has a slightly spiralled orbit to
account for its changing position in the seasons.
There’s also an anti-moon, which causes
eclipses, and is made of crackers so you can
eat it together with the cheese from the actual
moon.
Oh wait, that’s Wallace and Gromit.
How the sun stays up there is a different
matter since gravity isn’t real.
According to their theory, the earth is accelerating
upwards at 9.8 m/s2, like we’re on some
sort of interstellar pancake elevator.
So when you slip, you’re not falling, the
world is just high fiving you in the face.
All of NASAs achievements have been faked
of course and every shot of the round earth
is just a nifty bit of photo-shopping.
And when it comes to air travel, well all
GPS has been rigged so pilots think they are
travelling around a sphere but in fact are
just wasting all our time, taking the scenic
route in a big circle.
The approach of the believers is to follow
something called the Zetetic Method which
values sensory observation above everything
else.
So if the world looks flat, it must be flat,
right?
By this logic, that tree is not far away,
it’s just very small and Donald Trump is
exactly what he appears to be; an angry genetically
modified potato.
Billy Corgan sprang to fame in the 90s as
the face of the band Smashing Pumpkins, who
became one of the largest rock bands of the
era.
Their albums Mellon Collie and the Infinite
Sadness and Siamese Dream are ranked at 82
and 362 in the Rolling Stone Magazine’s
list of greatest albums of all time.
But Billy dreams no longer, recently describing
himself and Motley Crue drummer, Tommy Lee,
as “awake”.
This is conspiracy theory lingo for seeing
what is really going on behind the shadowy
curtain.
And one of his current theories of choice
is the notorious chemtrails.
When you look up into the sky, on a bright,
cloudless day, you’ll occasionally see the
white plume, left in the wake of a passing
plane.
Corgan, along with other stars such as Beck
and Kylie Jenner, believe that these clouds
are chemicals that the government is intentionally
pumping into the atmosphere.
Why would they do this?
Well perhaps to make people sick and get money
through pharmaceutical sales, maybe as some
sort of mind control technique, weather modification,
or perhaps just to use the sky as a gigantic
etch-a-sketch.
In reality, these trails are caused by a couple
of factors.
Most importantly, the exhaust coming from
the engines is hotter than the surrounding
air so this difference in temperature allows
water to condense and then freeze, thanks
to the ambient temperature of the high altitudes.
The particles in the exhaust, such as soot
and sulphur compounds, often serve as a site
for this condensation and freezing to take
place.
It’s also possible for the change in pressure,
caused by the wings and the body of the plane,
to act as a trigger.
These “contrails” (condensation trails)
can remain for minutes or hours, depending
on the atmospheric conditions at the time.
These trails may have an environmental impact,
since they can form sizeable clouds, but their
effect is limited to how they reflect heat
radiation, rather than the chemical content
of the clouds themselves.
Even if Chemtrail believers reject these explanations,
there’s still a major flaw in the theory
since, given the height of the planes, any
chemicals being sprayed out would dissipate
over hundreds of miles and lose their potency,
long before they reached the ground below.
But as for Billy, he still believes that we
cannot be saved.
Musicians, nutritionists and sports presenters
are one thing, but what happens when the world’s
most powerful man has a bizarre theory close
to his heart?
Former US president Ronald Reagan was an avid
believer in Numerology.
Numerology covers a range of superstitions
about the relationship of numbers with people
and events, often in the realm of the paranormal
and relating to divination and astrology.
Some form of number based belief is common
in many cultures, with lucky and unlucky numbers
being created from the sounds and symbols
of the words, or perhaps with their religious
connections, such as the Holy Trinity or the
twelve apostles in Christianity and May 4th
in Jediisim.
For Reagan, led largely by his wife Nancy
and her favourite astrologer Joan Quigley,
this mostly manifested itself in how he scheduled
certain events.
He delayed his inauguration as Governor of
California by 9 minutes to put it at the most
opportune moment.
He even used numerology to decide on the set
up of the Reykjavík Summit in 1986, where
Reagan and Gorbachev laid the groundwork for
the end of the cold war.
I would not have liked to have been the translator
who had to tell Gorbachev “we’re just
waiting untill Mars enters Uranus.”
Maybe his many psychics did help him though
as he was able to finally overcome the Curse
of Tippecanoe.
9th president William Harrison was involved
in a war with a Native American tribe called
the Shawnee, including the Battle of Tippecanoe.
Supposedly, a Shawnee prophet called Tenskwatawa
cursed Harrison and since then every president
elected on a 20th year anniversary of William
Harrison (1840) has died in office.
This includes Lincoln (1860), Garfield (1880),
McKinley (1900) and JFK (1960) as well as
Harding’s (1920) heart attack and Roosevelt’s
(1940) cerebral haemorrhaging.
But after Reagan became president the curse
seems to have been broken.
Thanks to Reagan’s belief in magic numbers,
George W Bush, elected in 2000, was able to
survive 3 attempted assignations, an attack
by a journalist’s shoe, choking on a pretzel
and was one of the lucky members of the White
house not to be shot in the face by Dick Cheney
while hunting.
It’s somehow reassuring to know that no
matter how famous or powerful you become,
you can still be scared of monsters under
the bed and believe in the magical cures and
treatments that could fix us all in an instant.
I personally, sometimes have the creepy feeling
that I’m being watched by mysterious strangers
from around the world.
Ha, silly isn’t it?